[Music]
on a successful TV show what do you
watch oh and I'm glad you brought this
up because this is really why I'm here
have you seen this show aside there's
other shows why show three very well
your show is doing great yeah there are
other shows out there that I feel just
need that extra little it's right there
for the taking
have you seen America's psychic
challenge no that's a great have you
seen this I am if you guys said be
honest we've seen America's psychic
challenge that's good cuz that's why I'm
here what should I have a feeling you're
gonna you know I'm saying you're gonna
go home from the end you're gonna look
for it you're gonna find it cuz I found
it this summer but you turns it on I'm
not sure I can't I can't do everything
everything don't find it they'll find it
that's the greatest show it's a bunch of
psychics the contestants are psychics
there's you believe in psychics no no
but here's the good news if it does not
get in a way of enjoying the show the
entertainment is very very strong and
here's the thing I watch this show and I
looked it up I was like how do you
figure this out this leg they're all
talking the same gibberish it's very
simple as I understand it you just start
with something I I could teach you to be
a psychic tomorrow you could be gout
they're making a little extra cash on
the side people be like Conan is
unbelievable so what's the trick you got
to start with like start look I've
always had this feeling about you you're
very very generous you're very generous
I feel that way but there's some people
perhaps some people where you hold back
a little bit right a little bit more
protective you know I'm talking about
sure yeah you talk about oh there's
something I'm getting by the way it
helps if you do something like this he's
like I'm getting I'm getting something
like this like a something it's it's
like a little uh something that's
electronic something that you have that
you own that's it's an electronic it
needs a battery but it's broken but you
thrown it out is this something that
makes sense there's a good chance
something everybody goes yes yes after I
have one of those lasted yes see so you
know where I'm getting there genius
I'm a guy I feel like his name is like
marker there's a mark and if it's
someone you don't know with someone
you're gonna know you see I'm saying
right and then don't get caught up and
if you miss things because people are
gonna remember the things that you got
yeah this is the thing you do you just
you know we could go on the road with
this looks and wanting to go on the
roads do it you've been talking about it
I've been talking about going on the
road all you as a psychic for a long
time
[Applause]